bonjour yahia zoubir merci de répondre à
nos questions sur arte france le chef du
pentagone en algérie après la visite du
directeur de la coopération militaire
russe ces derniers qui s'est entretenu
avec le chef d'état major de l'armée
algérienne selon un communiqué du
ministère algérien de la défense
coïncidence oui dans le sens où cette
visite dont les dessous ne sont pas
connues il n'y a pas eu de discussions
précise à ce que le contenu de cette de
ses discussions avec les algériens parce
que avec l'algérie les états unis n'a
même pas qu'on joue sur le plan de
stratégie sur le plan de la guerre
antiterroriste
moi je suppose que cette visite elle
rentre dans un cadre beaucoup plus large
c'est à dire cette offensive tous
azimuts de des états unis sur le
continent africain dans l'objectif est
bien sûr la chine et la russie puisqu'il
a est monté une présence accrue de la
chine dans le continent et le retour de
la russie en libye en particulier
donc il n'est pas très clair pour la
tunisie et le maroc c'est toujours ce
sont des alliés des etats-unis depuis de
très longue date depuis depuis leur
indépendance et même avant donc par
rapport à l'algérie s'est il s'agit de
savoir qu'est-ce qui de quoi il va
s'agir
mais la lutte antiterroriste le rôle de
l'algérie dans le sahel qui est très
connu
jerry
et l'avant garde et je l'envoie là c'est
important au niveau de la libye au
niveau 2 ou du moins là essayer de jouer
un rôle de réconciliation nationale en
libye l'ajustement l'instant vous parlez
beaucoup d'alibi en quoi le maghreb est
stratégique pour washington et moscou
bon le maghreb n'est pas aussi
stratégique qu'on le pense pour pour les
états unis
ça a toujours été les etats-unis ont
toujours considéré le maghreb comme
étant qui peut la responsabilité des
européens surtout la méditerranée
occidentale la méditerranée orientale
c'est autre chose le conflit palestinien
le la turquie la grèce c'est plus
important pour les états unis mais par
contre sur le plan du sahel sur la
présence américaine au bo sahel
oui ça devient très important c'est à
dire cette connexion si vous voulez
entre le maghreb et le sahel sont
importants pour la libye à présent parce
que les états unis s'étaient plus ou
moins retirer de la libye vers 2019 mais
le rôle accru de la russie a imposé
certaines appréhensions de la part des
états unis
qui ne voudrait pas par exemple qu'il y
ait une base une base navale en libye ou
autres une présence de la russie en
libye n'intéresse pas les états unis
voilà c'est pour contrer la déroute
c'est que toute cette visite
elle fait partie de la stratégie qui est
dans le document de la stratégie des
états unis les stratégies de sécurité
nationale où il faut contre contrer la
présence chinoise et et russes ont parlé
de la russie de la visite donc du
directeur de la coopération militaire en
algérie
mardi dernier un communiqué sune ceci
lors de cette rencontre les deux parties
ont tenu des discussions qui ont porté
sur l'état de la coopération militaire
entre les deux pays ont échangé des
analyses et des points de vue sur les
questions d'intérêt commun qu'elles sont
c'est
questions d'intérêt commun justement
entre l'algérie et la russie la russie
et l'algérie au nom d arrêt d aide d
accord sur tout depuis enfin yann
l'accord stratégie qui a été signé il
est presque vingt ans il y a l'algérie
achète tout 66 % 70 % sans armement de
la russie sur le plan politique
l'algérie et la russie partagent
beaucoup de points de vue sur la
situation internationale
je suis pas persuadé que par rapport à
la libye l'algérie est là et la russie
par sont sur le même la même longueur
d'onde
par contre il ya une relation qui dure
depuis avant l'indépendance est très
bonne relation qu'on avait que la chine
à gérer elle agit maintenant ce qui la
question à poser est comment les
etats-unis vont-ils réussir à jouer
justement cette 7,4 de dire de faire
pression comme ça a été le cas même dans
les pays du golfe de dire vous ne devrez
pas avoir de bonnes relations au des
relations trop étroites avec la chine la
chine qui a un régime des valeurs qui
sont contraires au nôtre et ces voix là
mais je ne pense pas que l'algérie qui a
toujours qui a toujours soutenu
si vous voulez une indépendance une
politique étrangère indépendante ne va
pas changer de cap parce que on lui a
dit durant une période électorale aux
états unis et un intérêt croissant pour
l'afrique
à part le sur le plan de de la défense
et je ne pense pas que cela change
beaucoup de choses pour le gouvernement
algérien c'est une visite assez positive
pour le l'image aussi bien
du chef d'état-major que pour le
président merci merci
yahia zoubir d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur de géopolitique à laquelle
business school